all right so thank you for coming
my name is Susie pot I work for it
through your labs and today I'm going to
talk about this four-step recipe for
text classification similarity
essentially you can think of these as
Lego blocks and I say it's embed and
code at end product and you can
rearrange these Lego blocks in various
ways right
so the inspiration for this talk is this
blog post by Matthew honorable Matthew
horrible is the creator of Spacey the
deep learning toolkit for Python this is
quite recent now he wrote it about six
months ago and some of it is kind of
outdated at the moment because deep
learning moves so fast but in general
the advice and actual ideas are you know
very much valid and I think it can be
very useful for us to kind of follow it
so before I start I want to acknowledge
the people who know the code that made
it possible
Chara's for the deep learning part I
used an NC k for most of the natural
language processing part I couldn't find
the logo for it so the best I could come
up with the book and scikit-learn for
some of its matrix some of its
transformers as well but most of it is
scikit-learn was kind of used on the
side right to give enough functionality
that I needed so I'm going to just set
up a little agenda like what we're going
to cover just to set the stage I'm going
to talk a little bit about energy
pipelines before deep learning if any of
you went to Alexander Jones tutorial
yesterday he covered this whole thing in
a lot more depth than I'm going to but
basically you know it's kind of setting
the stage right the second part is
basically I take each of these steps and
deconstruct them you know a kind of
explain what they are and so forth and
then I talk about three examples that I
did one for using document
classification and one for using
document similarity and one for using
sentence similarity so NLP pipelines for
deep learning essentially most of the
NLP that we see before deep learning
started from information retrieval right
requirements with search engines so
essentially what you had was you had
this corpus of text and you would
tokenize it and you create a drama
documentary tricks right so documents
down the road terms down the columns
right across the columns and you would
say that you know anywhere what the term
occurred you add a one so it becomes a
really large sparse matrix with the you
know the numbers the counts in that
matrix and then you could apply some
transformations such as maybe tf-idf and
you come up with tf-idf term document
matrix if you wanted it's still very
sparse because you're you know the fact
that cross part is still the size of the
vocabulary we're talking about now if
you wanted to densify it you would you
know maybe use Lda or SVD to do feature
reduction or topic modeling and you
would end up with a topic document
matrix right the topic less topics and
the columns but same number of the
documents and the object of this whole
thing is to mainly you know feed it into
something like an SVM a support vector
machine for document classification some
kind of another kind of related approach
was you know is from the machine
learning side of the house so machine
learning has a recipe of how to deal
with categorical variables that you turn
it into a one heart vector um so if you
can see if you think of a text as
basically a bunch of words and each word
being categorical variable essentially
you're talking about a large category
space which is equal to the size of a
category right and within that each word
occupies exactly one position right so
that's that's another way to look at it
and again the the pipeline is kind of
similar except that once you tokenize
you create a vocabulary right you create
words and you create IDs for it and then
you could take something you know like
this a man is riding a bicycle right
this is my sentence is basically a
string of words it's sequence of words
and using this vocabulary where you can
look up a word and get an ID you can
reduce it to a sequence of numbers
sequence of integers and then you know
using the sequence of integers you can
now create
turned out moon matrix but this is
slightly different not exactly the same
but it's still a time document matrix
right the problem with this is that this
kind of one hot encoding does not have
distribution on semantics to the word
level what do I mean by distribution
semantics so if you look at the sentence
again and instead say man is riding a
motorcycle right typically you would
think the bicycle and motorcycle are
similar but if you take the word vectors
and you do a cosine similarity you'll
get zero because they have one set
different places right so at the word
level there is no concept of meaning in
the word vectors in one hub tectors so
the next step kind of comes up is you
know word embeddings and what embeddings
kind of have this thing where the words
kind of inherit their meaning right
based on how it occurs so essentially a
word embedding kind of create similar
vectors if they occur in similar
contexts right so in a sense they kind
of encode the meaning of the world so
there are various flavors the nice thing
about word embeddings today is that
there's a bunch of them available for
free and trained on large corpora so one
of them is what Tuvok so there are two
flavors over to vex SIBO where you
predict the word from the context and
ship gram where you do the other bow
direction
kid gram is generally more popular and
the image here shows you basically the
skip gram how it's actually set up
essentially it's a classification task
and except that it's on unsupervised
data you are you're depending on the
structure of language to give you the
structure right
so what you are doing is you slide a
moving window across your sentences and
you take that word as the input and the
neighbors as the outputs right so
essentially what you're doing here is
you're sending in a one hot vector for
say in the second case right you are
sending a one heart vector for men and
you're sending it through this
autoencoder kind of thing where you you
know kind of condense it to a hidden
state which is the size of the embedding
you want and then you again expand it
out to
sighs the vocabulary and you're trying
to train this network so it can predict
in this case a and is right so you send
in man it should pretty predictive you
send in - you're predicting right once
you have something that is reasonably
trained you can now extract the weights
from here and that's your embedding
right so you have your vocabulary to
embedding right so so each each row
would be a vocabulary and the actual row
for that is the word embedding for that
word glove is kind of different glove
you start off with this whole vocabulary
in advance you do a word to context kind
of co-occurrence matrix first and then
you factorize the matrix to create a
word to embedding and hidden to context
rate so and you take the left hand side
once you're trained fast text is similar
to what you've accepted works on sub
words which is which makes it much
better
so basically trigrams or pentagrams of
characters instead of actually full
words so that's word embeddings so now
that we know about wording bearings
let's talk about the first step in the
four step recipe the embed step right so
here we are using so if you look at this
diagram you'll see it's almost the same
as the one two slides ago the only
difference is that we have replaced the
one hot vector that we generated with
the pre-trained vector that we got from
one of these third-party M bearings
right
so essentially you do the same exact
same thing you create your vocabulary
and then you you know look up your
sentence you convert your sentence to a
string of wins and the embed step
basically does it takes an int it
creates a vector right and so the idea
is that you know and since its sentence
is a sequence of ins essentially you end
up with a sequence of word vectors which
is basically a matrix right so you could
think of a sentences being matrix
the second step is encode and so encode
takes again
we you know we kind of skipped which
covered a little bit from the previous
one where you take a sequence of vectors
and you convert it into some kind of
matrix right so the naive way is to
basically concatenate all these vectors
on the short side and create this matrix
right but the input state here talks
about slightly different it says that
okay you want to encode it such that the
meaning of each word in the context of
the sentence is retained right so let's
say you had in a five-word sentence you
had two words which were really indicate
about the meaning you want that to have
more impact right in the final matrix
that you get so that's what this does
and typically you do it with a
bidirectional STM or a vibrational group
so Alice TM is long short term memory
and gru is the gated recurrent children
these are drop-in replacements for
recurrent unit recurrent neural network
since and you know usually you can get
this like third party you know I used
Terrace and Karis has layers which are
which have lsdm functionality built in
so you don't actually have to think
about what's going on inside and the the
reason for bidirectional is basically
because you want you know words at the
beginning to have the same impact of the
words at the end right so you read one
left to right one right to left and you
concatenate or add them or something so
that way you get you know all the words
get equal impact the next step is at end
basically attend is you take you just
got a sentence matrix in my previous
step right now you want to reduce it to
a vector and again the knife way to
reduce it to a vector is maybe do a max
pool or do an average pool rate so
essentially you look at this vector and
you say okay I want to find the maximum
here you know of each column and I
create this little row so that's my max
pool vector or I just add them up and
average them again that's the average
pool okay but again we don't want to do
something nice we want to basically have
another layer which basically kind kind
of tries to minimize the information
loss from the matrix to the vector right
so you you want to do something smart
and actually I spent quite a lot of time
trying to figure out what thing to do
and reading papers and so forth so I'll
actually cover that in quite a bit of
depth and so from the blog post they're
basically they talk about two types of
matrix two types of attention mechanisms
one that takes the matrix and a vector
and creates a vector and one that takes
two matrices and creates a vector and
while I was researching there was a
third one that I kind of third and a
fourth one that I kind of found where
you take a matrix by itself and you try
to reduce it to getness no additional
vectors and there is another one where
you take a matrix and you in the process
of reducing it to a vector you actually
learn another vector which is called the
context vector right so I'm going to
cover those in a little bit of detail
only because well especially if you work
with Kerris all the other steps they
actually have layers already available
right attention is the only one which is
kind of non-standard and that's probably
why they don't have the layers but you
know so I had to build my own custom
layers which I'll also talk about so
it's not that you know really hard
saying case so I start with the first
type of attention there are four types
so in this case if you look at the this
diagram to the right on the top this is
kind of the high level view you take a
matrix you pass it to attend and you get
a vector the other view which I find
more useful especially if you are trying
to implement this thing is the equations
right and so it's ang and the diagram of
this here is basically the equations in
diagram form right so essentially what
you get is from the output of the lsdm
that you got that page and you have two
weight vectors or the weight vector W
and a bias vector B which you learn
right
and during the training process where
you you know you have this entire energy
pipeline and you have it's a training
process right so you are trying to train
the network and during that propagation
you start off with random values for the
W and B and during that propagation you
would basically update it each time
right and over time once the network is
trained this W and B are now adapted to
the task at hand so essentially the
attention is also learning right so
that's something to you know that eluded
me for a long time but then I kind of
got it so I just wanted to kind of share
videos so essentially what you do is you
take the input signal H you multiply it
with the weight matrix and add a bias
and you take the ten each of that so the
tan H kind of scratches it between minus
1 and 1 and then you take that and you
run a softmax on the remaining on the
output
so what softmax does is basically it
creates it it again pushes it between
well not pushes it it makes it so that
it adds up to one so essentially these
are probabilities so I think intuitively
you can think of these the alphas as the
probability of each word in your
sentence right how much to weight them
and then the final step is you take the
original signal and you multi-product it
with this alphas and then you sum it
over all time steps and that's the
vector you get right so this this is
proposed by some researcher called
raffle and his team and I have I have
references at the end so you have the
papers there so you can just read it up
yourself but as you can see the
intuition is basically to select the
most important element from each time
step right you know essentially at each
word so you take the most important word
there and as I mentioned before weights
W and B are learnable and depends on the
target and I'm going to show you the
code here I'm not going to show you code
for everything mainly because it's kind
of repetitive and once you know one you
know the others so essentially this is
the custom layer so you can see here you
know I'm extending layer
and then there is a bit of boilerplate
that you can find from the Karis custom
layers page as well so you need to add
this you need to call the superclass
right so in your in it and you need to
call the superclass in your build and in
your build you basically set up these
random you know the weights that are
going to be populated with random values
so here I have another weight vector I'm
initializing into normal values and the
y vector and initializing zeros and you
can see the shapes here and so for the
shape is in terms of the input shape
that I get and similarly the actual
equations that we talked about are there
in this call method right
so it's essentially I'm using the
carriage backend to implement these
equations and basically you know it just
follows the equations if you look at the
equations when you look at this like
one-to-one correspondence
okay all right yes why do I have three
activations
so the challenge is basically so when
you're when your input comes in you want
to kind of squash it down because
otherwise the sizes get too large the
input signal sizes and when you try to
back propagate the explode right I
actually found this and in a later one
and I ultimately ended up patching it
with the vas normalization layer after
this so that kind of does the same thing
but Tennessee yes
um okay so there are four kinds right so
let's see here oh yeah sure the
questioner was the question was what are
the mathematical operations that are
used in at end right so so this is the
first set so I talked about four
different kind of attention rate I said
there are four I found and this is the
first kind this is the easiest one right
so this is not activation this is
attention activation is when you take
I'm sorry ah
yes but in this case it is well yeah 10
H is also is it's an activation function
not really it's it's actually the
purpose is different in case of when you
are trying to do an activation you are
trying to squash your input into a
certain range right and whereas here you
are trying to take a signal and you are
trying to you know kind of a qunit
almost like you know how you tune your
radio right you get different signals
coming in and you just come to the right
place where the weights are all cancel
out and you get the right signal it's
exactly that right so you're trying to
learn something which is kind of
maximizes your signal right so any
answer this is the first kind of
attention I showed you code the second
kind okay this is still the first kind
okay
ah yes so so the second kind is kind of
similar to this except there is one
different straight as before you have a
matrix you use an attention mechanism to
create a vector but in the process you
learn a context vector as well and this
context vector used to further you know
the influence the output right
and again equations if you look at it is
very similar the first equation is
identical right to what you saw before
the second equation however is a little
different so now instead of so you have
this e that you just got out of the ten
H and now you are multiplying this
learned context vector along with that
right and then you're taking a softmax
so again it's a little different
produces slightly different results
proposed by Lin here so I just turn on
blindly copied the paper so that's how
the proportion the only thing I have
done here is that they all had different
notations so I kind of normalized a
notation for my own sanity right and
yeah so I for presentation purposes so
this is how you do it again as you can
see the you come they use the learned
context vector and that comes in you
know as the result of the learning
itself right third one is again this is
yeah sure the U is constructed as it is
learned as a result of this whole thing
if you look at the second equation right
so the whole point is that this is a
just a set of operations right as as you
go through the network forward these are
the operations that are executed right
and as you go backwards once you know
the result right you during training you
have levels right so the labels you
basically find the difference in what
you predicted and the labels and you
calculate the gradient and you move the
gradient backwards right now as you move
the gradient backwards all these
functions are differentiated also right
because you want the gradients to
propagate back and as a result and
because you want to minimize the
difference here right at the end between
the prediction levels your weights keep
changing right it learns as a you know
the weights that you have they are
basically you know they learn you start
with random rate and they kind of
converge to correct values so
essentially this is another hyper
parameter that you're tuning and I think
about it in machine learning that's
exactly that it is yes it can be that's
the whole idea really
I mean you are introducing another
variable to make it learn better you
know we're better is kind of by in a
definition right it depends on what you
are trying to do your task right so your
your task will determine what is better
right the interpretation is basically
you can think of it as weights that try
to maximize the information that you
extract right so essentially if you if
you think of for instance in terms of
translation right between some language
and some other language so if you take a
sentence in a source language essential
and target language you want to take
give most importance to the words in the
source language which mean a lot in the
target language right so that is
basically interpretation it's basically
rewriting the vector right so anyways so
third one is kind of a variation on the
same the previous two but instead of
matrix you get a matrix and a vector the
vector is produced put provided by you
the user right and it could be the
contents vector so if you had so you had
an LS TM that created the matrix right
you could take the last one because the
last one is the final context as your as
your vector you could take a max pool of
that and produce another vector you
could even you know take another process
itself could come up with another
separate vector and you could merge the
two together
and essentially here you are taking
these two and you know you're sending it
again you're creating a vector equation
wise
the only difference is up in the where
you create your the you know the raw
signal that is damaged you basically add
this new weight you and the context
vector that you were given right and
everything else is the same and this
this was proposed by another researcher
and the scheme called show and his team
and again the intuition is here you know
it's kind of a variation the same thing
it select the most important element
from each time step and weighted with
the learn multiple for provided context
vector you just make it more and more
complex sentence but eventually you know
it's just three waiting the thing
finally we come to the most necessary
finally we came come to the most complex
one the matrix to matrix
yeah so you have to input matrices and
it produces one vector and basically you
so here you can think of this second
matrix or if you remember the previous
one where it had one matrix and one
provided context vector right so you can
actually manufacture the context vector
by constructing and alignment of the two
matrices right if you do a similarity
you know if you do a so in the hip here
if you notice the the e on the left is
at an edge just as you saw before with
the wnh the e on the right is another
ten edge but now you have these two
matrices and then you multiply them
together and you get a similarity matrix
right now using the similarity matrix
you then take the softmax of the
similarity matrix and you multiply it
with the original signal right so if you
look at the diagram here is easier to
understand so you could take these two
signals combine them together you get
your similarity alignment and then you
take this the softmax of this and you
combine the original signal with the
softmax of the other one right and
similarly this signals with the softness
to the other one so this creates your
context vectors for the other guy it and
once you do that you again do very
similar things you basically do a ten
each of that and you you know you sum
over all the time steps and then once
you are done it concatenates you
concatenate the two and you produce your
bigger vector so this is double the size
if you concatenate you could do other
things you could do someday forever
right the code for this is slightly more
hairy but again it's just a net in the
build again it's not term it's all there
in github the github is there in the
slides and you know go ahead and look at
it and you will actually in it's easier
to read then talk about I guess
the final step is the predict step the
again the predict step is basically it
takes a reduced vector that we just got
out of my attention and it creates a
label right and to do that you basically
it's just a basic fully connected
Network right and so generally you use
the shallow or fully connected Network
you could also if you are looking to do
regressions for instance say you wanted
to do ranking of similarity or something
like that you could change this the top
at the instead of doing a softmax and
and actually you can get it even if you
do a softmax you just get a bunch of
probabilities right and then when you do
classification you choose the highest
probability one but once you get your
bunch of probabilities you could treat
it education right so you could just
redo this course so you could use it as
a regression thing as well
so this is basically the setup that you
know the four steps they will talked
about so first example let's go on to
that so my data set was the twenty news
group set aside I got it out of
scikit-learn they come prepackaged with
it so you can download it so it had
40,000 training records 10,000 test
records they're just new school postings
about maybe you know four or five
sentences long slightly longer sometimes
come and the output is the the task here
is to figure out what category they're
in and they're 20 categories so output
in a number of classes is 20 so I tried
various you know subsets of this
four-step procedures so my first step
was n bed and predict initially so
essentially this is the bag-of-words
idea so I treat a sentence as a bag of
words and a document of the bag of
sentences right so what I do is for I
you know Bart organized the text and
then I create my vocabulary and for each
word I do my embedding I use gloves here
as my third-party embedding and then I
get my gloves word vector right and then
since I sent into the bag of words
I basically add all the vectors
I create my sentence sector and average
them again and again
since my document is a bragger sentences
I take my sentence vectors add them up
average them again and then I send it to
a you know fully connected layer the
predict year and basically get my
prediction so this is like really simple
this is how I used to do it before I
learned how to do the other stuff and I
can show you the code for this this is
like really simple let's see so most of
it is people thing and you know getting
it to fit the thing here is the the
network definition and you can see a
kind of a diagram for it it's really
simple two layers with dropouts on both
I think dropouts and one or not maybe
two
yeah so and then when I I train it for
18 10 10 epochs certain J 10 epochs and
I get an accuracy of 31% on my test set
right so I basically train it on the
40,000 I test it on the remaining 10,000
and okay
and then so this was my kind of my
baseline so it gave me you know it gives
me like 71 percent or so the second one
was where I actually do the embed encode
in the predict right so I actually have
a second encoding layer so little more
complex here because since again you
know to create a sentence vector I have
to encode word vectors right and to
create document vectors have to encode
sentence vectors so they are actually
two separate steps so essentially the
top box here shows you a sentence
encoder it takes ideal word IDs that we
just got runs it through embed creates
word vectors runs it through the encode
step and creates a sentence vector right
now one cares can allow you to it allows
you to return the whole sequence you
know so in in case I said recurrent
sequences were true it would take
assuming this sentence had three words
in it it would return me three vectors a
matrix or size you know one of the
dimension was three right but I can also
say return sequences false which gives
me the context vector so it
automatically context defies the output
right so that's how I get my sentence
vector and once I had this model I embed
it here into my other my document
network right so each of these guys I
just embed the reference of this and
here and now I am given a sequence of
you know this is essentially a sentence
the sequence events and then I send it
to my sentence model it gives me a
sentence vector I encode that it now
gives me a document director right and I
take the document vector send it to my
predict step and I get my label again
the code here is you know so it's
slightly more complex here so I'm going
to show you the code I declare it in two
steps
so here is my sentence vector sorry my
sentence model I have an embedding here
and I send this embedding through a
bi-directional GRU right and so notice
that I talked about the embed step right
the embed step is already provided
the the encode step is already basically
this it's already provided right and so
I I get this and I get my output which
is a sentence vector so none is the web
size here and then I take my sentence
vector which I just said sent encoder
right I now embed it here in my document
vector so I have my inputs my embedding
is basically a time distributed version
of the senton coder so they say so time
distributed basically says on my second
dimension of my input i basically spread
the senton coder across all of the
dimensions right so that's what I've
done here and as before just like we had
before I take the output of this and I
send it through this bi-directional gru
again right and so that is that is my
hierarchical model and this one takes
again I train it over to any box and it
gives me slightly better results about
77% all right so the next step is
basically adding
so the next step I added the attention
there as well right so again you won't
see much difference the sentence model
now the encoder emits matrix here and
then that matrix goes through an i10
step and that creates a sentence vector
similarly the the document encoder also
emits document matrix again gets to a
attend step and creates the document
vector everything else is the same and
so I tried so since I had to build three
different kinds of attention that uses
matrices as the input I tried running it
through all three right and the best
result that I got was through the first
one about 82% so here again if you want
to look at this right so remember I
talked about return sequences right so
now I'm I want to him you know I want
the emitter matrix right
so I said return sequence equals true so
it's actually turning each time step
done and so I take the output of that I
send it to my attention there here and
that's that's pretty much all the
difference here and similarly I do the
same thing here I you know send it to my
attention layer here and this one gives
me about eighty two point four percent
right and when I when I actually did the
you know so the other kinds of attention
that I did boy let's see
so there's a slight difference here so
when I okay not this one either sorry
so you remember I talked about sending a
user-defined vector along with the
matrix right so I did it here in this
way
so I took my sent encoder the output
right and then I created my sent vector
which is basically a global max pool of
the sent encoder right so I just added
global Max pool into this whole equation
this one actually did not perform as
well as far as I remember Oh this also
is slightly less eighty-two point eighty
two point zero that was eighty two point
four right and so that's that's
basically my what I did with the
document classification and here are my
results you should basically ignore the
red and the green one because those are
just training and validation I my in a
plotter was set up to do that
essentially you're looking at the test
accuracy results right so then as you
can see the bag of words is you know
works the least has the least
performance and I view the tension you
kind of go into the higher numbers our
next document the next example I have is
a document similarity example again just
like we talked about before in the
document classification this is a
hierarchical model where the sentence
model is actually embedded in the
document model and I'll derive this data
so for the data I basically took the
test data for my twenty newsgroups I
created tf-idf vectors from that and
then I did an all pairs on this ten
thousand and then I took the top five 95
percentile and over data as the positive
and the zero to five percentile has
negative and but unfortunately the data
was not really good there is only a
point zero two difference in cosine
similarity between the best in the worst
and so I tried with without attention
and with attention so I'll just explain
the diagram here for of it so if you
look again these are the word IDs these
are the you know so for each word ID I
do an MA
I get a word vector I take a sequence of
word vectors do an encode I get a
sentence matrix if I want to use
attention otherwise I can get a sentence
vector and then I do an encode on that
and I get a sentence vector sorry I
attend on that and I get a sentence
vector and then I take I do an encode on
a group of sentence vectors and I get a
document matrix and I do this for my
left hand cinema both both sentences for
which I'm calculating the similarity and
then I attend on those two vectors and I
created you know a similarity document
similarity vector right and then I do a
predict on that and I predict whether
it's you know similar or not similar
it's a binary thing unfortunately the
results that I got was not great as you
can see that Gina barely moves across
the three different types and so
essentially what I did was initially I
tried it without attention so without
attention I dependent on the LSTs to
encode it for me and then I just
concatenated the two vectors document
vectors and I predicted on that and then
I did attention only for sentence
encodings like here sorry here and and
attention for both sentence encoding and
I'm sorry
so this attention is always there in
both cases and this is the one that I
did we can without so my theory here is
that you know the data itself is so
noisy that when I added attention it
actually created it made it worse so you
know I still have to look at it but and
I really wanted to basically show you
how it works rather than kind of
focusing on the results so which is why
it's you know is there it's to look at
the code here let's look at the final
one okay
if you look at the code this is the
sentence network this should be very
familiar by now I mean this is I just
reused the sentence Network from before
and here the the document network is the
document similarity Network so I use
I create my left hand document network
which creates an encoding basically you
know outputs the matrix here right the
document matrix for the left hand
document another one that creates an
output matrix for the right hand
argument and then this is an attention
there that takes concatenates the two
and this is where I use the batch
normalization because my numbers are
going too high and it was not learning
anything and then after there is this is
just prediction and that's how I got it
and okay so this is this is basically
the network the next one I tried with
slack is similar but actually simpler to
some extent this is a sentence model
sentence similarity model once more this
is you know it's got two two kind of
heads coming in you're starting with
word vectors embedding encoding alright
you're creating a sentence matrix and
now you create your sentence matrix on
both sides and then you do an attention
on that and you create your fare vector
right and then you do a predict on it
this time it actually went worse because
with attention I actually got worse
results once again I mean I wanted to
basically and then it's possible that I
have some bug in my attention layer as
well and I'm looking at it I don't know
yet I try to follow the paper you know
like word by word but I think I'm right
I don't know yeah so it does point to a
bug I guess you know if so what I will
look at it and you know I haven't yet
code boys
this is so much simpler than the
previous one once again you have the
sentence encoder here right and then you
have this full network which you know
you have the left hand side in the right
hand side and you send it to our
attention send it to batch normalization
then you basically run a verdict on it
and that's what you get from here and so
I'm kind of reaching the end now and so
I'm going to summarize basically what we
talked about so essentially this you
know this is a four-step recipe what I
liked about it is that it's the kind of
principle it's kind of a way to you know
Lego block I is the whole process right
so if you think of it's kind of a higher
level of abstraction right so if you
work with carriers it already gives you
little layers that you can string
together and make your network this
actually goes one step further it
actually looks at processes and then you
can string those together and make new
networks right and each process is
basically you can think of it as a
matrix transformation right so it takes
a matrix of one dimension creates
another other face right and it's all
very well-defined and yeah and and so
the embed state basically leverage the
availability of many pre-trained
embeddings the encode state uses
bi-directional Astrium or you know
nowadays you can also use CNN but I
didn't cover it here attention is of
three main types matrix to vector with
or without in case it context context
matrix and matrix a matrix injected to
vector and matrix and matrix to vector
essentially it computes the summary
respect to input or context and the
predict step converts the vector to a
probability distribution and then yeah
it creates a label for you and that's
pretty much it I don't know what
happened to this okay not never mind
yes something is wrong here but so here
are my references the first one is the
actual blog post that led to this talk
the second one is you know
this is the blog post I read to
understand how to build my hierarchical
Network where I embedded one Network
into another the third one is actually I
want to point it out because this is the
place I thought that has the best
explanation for attention it talks you
know it shows you attention in terms of
pictures it shows you attention in terms
of equations and it's really good I mean
you should you know if you're increasing
attention and implementing it you should
look at it the rest of them are the four
papers I kind of implemented for my four
different flavors of attention and
that's pretty much it you know the code
is all here
the first is github where you find all
the code the slides are up already
that's here my email is this and my
twitter handle is this so in case you
guys want to get in touch with me later
and also a co-author and I my next
colleague and I we wrote a book on Keros
and the publisher basically you know it
was kind enough to give me a discount
code so in case you guys want you know
this is there are three basic books and
carriers right now or one written by the
author of care so maybe that's the book
is the best but you know yeah but you
know this is there I mean just say okay
I'm done thank you thank you